sparen sparen sparen so sagen es uns
täglich der wirtschaftsminister und auch
der kanzler aber anstatt mit gutem
beispiel voraus zu gehen wird bei ihnen
nicht gespart der ausbau des kanzleramts
david nach petrikirche immer teurer und
noch teurer es ist eine kostenexplosion
dort im kanzleramt auf unsere kosten auf
steuerzahlerkosten
das deutsche kanzleramt die größte
regierungszentrale der welt denn die
schaltzentrale der macht wird umgebaut
und verdoppelt ihre fläche dieser umbau
wird immer teurer 600 millionen euro für
400 neue büros
23.000 quadratmeter neue fläche mit kita
und heli landeplatz
das kanzleramt 80 millionen deutsche
sind von dem abhängig was hier
entschieden wird die schaltzentrale der
macht von hier aus werden die geschicke
des volkes gelenkt im berliner volksmund
heißt der bau schlicht waschmaschine
nach bild -informationen sollen zu den
geplanten 600 millionen euro noch 30
millionen euro mehrkosten obendrauf
kommen der grund sind spezielle auflagen
des berliner senats sowie umweltschutz
auflagen
us-zentrum der macht wächst und wächst
und wird immer teurer und das mitten in
einer historischen krise inflation
energiekrise pandemie wie teuer darf das
kanzleramt da werden hast so ein
gewaltiger umbau noch in die zeit fest
steht mit diesem umbau wird das deutsche
kanzleramt wohl die teuerste
waschmaschine der welt
[Musik]